The process of making is the point of it.
This needs to be a kind of ballet.
>> If anybody can copy [indistinct], it's
not art.
[violin]
>> There's no carving in wood or in stone
or knots on a rug that are going to look anything
near like what pleats do when they express
a line.
>> Lots of people talk about the reality of
a [indistinct] elephant in origami.
Does it look real?
Does it look like an elephant?
But, it's a piece of paper, and, of course,
it can't look like an elephant.
>> I think, at heart, one of the things that
makes us human -- that's both our strength
and our weakness -- is a need to change things.
It's also the heart of the appeal of origami,
exploring the surprising magic of just how
far you can change that square only by folding
it.
>> What are the limits -- the physical limits
-- of this art form?
>> When you put a crease in the paper, you're
essentially changing the memory of that piece.
>> Origami is just a way to get your hands
dirty with math.
It becomes your laboratory for doing mathematics.
>> Whenever there's a need in the industry
to take a flat sheet and somehow make it smaller,
there is potential for origami to have an
application.
>> In science, this is the most creative you
can be.
We are artists whether we do science or whether
we build sculpture.
>> Well, first, thanks to everybody here and
Paul and Brian, it's a real pleasure and we're
flattered that you were able to make this
happen today.
I don't want to take up too much time myself,
because, really, the people who you want to
ask questions to are the artists who are in
the back.
First, actually, I'll call up Sally Rosenthal.
She's the executive producer, and she's an
amazing person.
And then, Bernie Peyton.
Please, you guys should just get up.
This is informal.
Yes.
Chris, Jeremy, Robert, Michael, Richard.
Did I miss anybody?
We've had a couple.
You guys actually are -- yeah.
This is quite special to have all these people
here.
We have a bunch of local people and that have
helped.
There's an enormous amount of brain talent
right here.
So, and many of them have actually brought
some of their work.
I know Chris Palmer has some new things to
show you.
And Michael has Wilbur.
And I think, Chris also has a flower tower
here.
Jeremy might have a flasher.
This is the papermaker; is that you?
>> Can you describe what's involved in making
paper, and what's special about the paper
that's used for this?
>> Sure.
When I first became inspired to become an
origami artist, it was because of the work
of Akira Yoshizawa, who we saw in the film,
and his work just had that artist touch.
So I tried to do this as a young boy with
ordinary paper.
First, I thought it was me, and then I thought,
"It's the paper."
I luckily lived in a papermaking town, and
I began to study it, and realized there was
chemistry involved and material selection
and paper-forming techniques.
So, over the years, my three goals in the
papermaking, starting from age 16, were: the
foldability.
I wanted it to respond to my touch, so it
worked like playing a fine instrument.
I could put the expression I wanted.
I wanted the works to last a long time.
You know, you put a lot of work into these
things, and maybe people buy them, and they
should not crumble and fade.
And then the third thing was, of course, I
wanted to be able to do this whenever I really
needed it.
I had to set myself up to make paper on demand.
So, I did a lot of research.
Essentially, we use plant fibers, abaca, which
is from a banana plant, or hemp -- really
good, long, strong stuff, like they use in
paper money.
You grind that up in water.
And then you can color it, use permanent pigments.
You float the stuff in water and use various
size screens to screen out layers of pulp
-- thinner or thicker -- press it and dry
it, and you've got paper.
So, our paper can be as thin as tissue and
as strong as paper money at the same time.
Wilbur is folded from thicker paper, and when
we fold the paper, we moisten it slightly
sometimes.
That's called "wet folding."
You can see the stylistic difference.
But that's in a nutshell what paper making
is all about.
Richard is our other papermaking master.
>> Most people associate origami with origami
paper which was developed in the 1800s to
support the Froebel Kindergarten Program,
where they did a lot of paper folding in Europe,
and then it spread through the U.S. and Japan.
And sure, you can make origami from anything
you can fold, but to make origami art, you
need to use artist materials that are going
to last.
That's the difference.
>> I've seen some images floating around the
Internet by artists who, instead of fold paper,
they just make creases.
And they use these creases in such a way to
make -- usually a representational scene.
Have you seen this type of art that, again,
instead of actual folds, they're just like
minor creases in what remains a flat piece
of paper, and do you consider that origami?
>> Have you guys seen that?
>> So, just the crease pattern, and then,
it's folding up to make a geometic pattern?
Or what is it making?
>> No folding.
Usually it looks like a room or maybe like
an outdoor scene.
I mean, lots of, it kind of tries to use -- painterly
three dimensionality but again they're not
really folds.
It's just a series of creases on an otherwise
flat pieces of paper, that create a picture,
or something like that, but it doesn't actually
fold up into anything.
>> Like a relief kind of?
>> Yeah, kind of.
>> Robert.
>> So, I've seen this.
Oh, sorry, I'm Robert Lang.
So, I'm one of the artists in the film.
I've seen this, and for those who haven't,
it is low relief.
Effectively, they're scoring the paper, the
artist is scoring, making shallow creases
in the paper.
And so, the image that you get comes from
both the fold lines itself, and the slight
changes in angle of the paper, when lit appropriately,
give height and contrast, so you can see representation
images.
And, to me, everyone has a different definition
of origami.
My definition of origami is, It's an art form
where folds are the primary means of creating
the structure.
So it doesn't have any rules about whether
it's one or two sheets, or whether you can
or can't cut, but folding has to be primary.
And so, in my view that type of folding, as
well as the nondeterministic folding, otherwise
known as crumpling [indistinct] is, in fact,
another branch of origami.
>> I think this doesn't really answer the
question.
I think the root of the question is, How are
they made? Right?
>> Well, that's another interesting question.
>> And I have my own -- I mean, who knows
for sure, but I've looked at them really carefully.
And I would suggest there's some sort of laser
work, you know, scoring -- that's just my
own personal thing.
I have no proof, so anybody -- that's everybody's
to their own personal interpretation.
>> Well, the word "origami" is gradually,
in my opinion, becoming equal to the word
music.
By the way, I'm Michael LaFosse, the papermaker,
designer too.
And today, we realize that whatever anyone
wishes to call music, or even the word art
for that reason, might really be up to their
own decision.
So, when Robert mentioned that, the thing
that occurred to me is, I wonder what the
folks who actually make that work of art wish
to -- or decided to -- call it.
That might be a bit more interesting to hear,
you know, their answer of what they're calling
it.
Maybe they don't want to call it "origami."
I don't know.
I think of it as origami, because as Robert
said, if its primary expression is folds in
paper, no matter the method of getting them
into the paper, that can categorically be
origami, like the word "music".
>> Hi my name is Natalie Su.
My question for all the artists is, "Once
you have the final product, is there anything
that you either spray on the product to make
it last for a long time?
For example, lacquer or, is it more like determinant
on the paper that you use final pieces it's?"
>> Yeah.
Well I'd say that's -- there is some people
in the wide world of the craft of origami
that have been known to paint their final
thing with lacquer.
It's a small set of people.
And it makes it much different object.
It kind of freezes it in place, and takes
it away from that idea that that process brought
it there, in my opinion.
>> And, well, yeah.
Sometimes, in order to make it more durable,
it is necessary.
And, Jeremy has some examples of that sort
of thing for performing.
If it needs to actually open and close many
times, then some treatment is necessary.
That's kind of an interesting subject that
has movement.
>> Hi.
Richard Alexander.
We do some commercial installations, some
which are permanent.
We have to spray the tops of the origami mobiles
with maybe an acrylic spray that will allow
the workers to clean them and keep them dusted
so they look fresh.
Window displays are often up for a short period
of time, and there's a coating.
When people make origami jewelry, depending
on the age of people that are going to be
wearing it, jewelry sold to younger children,
they will dip in two-part epoxy to make it.
>> That's what I was referring to that some
people do that.
>> Here's some examples of paper that's been
treated for utility with tape.
>> And so this is -- okay.
So, this one is first folded out of a large
sheet of paper.
I couldn't find that big one, so I pieced
several together to get this big of a square.
And then after I folded it, I did paint it,
and I reinforced it on the back laminating.
>> So, there's some plastic in there.
>> Yes.
And this one has lasted me a few years, actually,
opening it during all my performances.
And these are some other ones that I laminated.
And, with acrylic paint, which is also -- acrylic
paint is also very flexible, so that's what
I use.
[laughter]
>> It was hinted towards earlier, but I didn't
get the chance to follow up.
You mention, or said with some disdain, that
they might have been using lasers in that
paper-creasing process.
I didn't see any tools or maybe I missed it.
I didn't see many tools in this video.
Is it kind of looked down upon in the origami
community to use like the small hooking tools
to make these teeny creases?
Or did I just not see that part of the process?
>> I think you just didn't see that part of
the process, and also different people do
-- some people use bone [indistinct], and
some people like to laser cut or etch a little,
very lightly, with very little power, to make
creases.
So, it's there and around.
And people use small tools for fine work as
well.
>> I just want to clarify, since I made that
disdaining comment.
I just think that origami, it's okay to use
tools, but if it's.
It's sort of important to present like -- if
you use cuts, for instance, then you would
put a work on display.
And maybe, people in this day and age might
consider that that model doesn't have cuts.
And then, when -- I mean, that happened to
me the first time I made a crab.
I wanted to make a crab.
I saw it in the book, and I was really excited
to make it, and then it sort of turned out
it had cuts and I was like.
[disappointed sound]
And so yeah, it's just presenting things,
I think, it's important to have some sort
of description of the medium, the method in
order to really present an artwork.
And that's just my own personal opinion.
>> I was just going to mention: A lot of people,
including myself, do use tools.
I use anything, ranging from tweezers, glasses,
reading glasses sometimes, [laughter] and
on some pieces, I've also used laser-scriber
to scribe creases.
My view is, if tools help you create a better
artwork -- and what Jeremy alluded to, you're
not claiming that you are doing something
different than what you are doing -- then
I think any tool is a good thing, just as
if you are a painter, using a brush to apply
the paint, rather than spitting it out of
your mouth like the old people did, is a good
thing as well.
>> I've seen images floating around of someone
who used toilet paper rolls to create faces.
Have you seen this?
Is that artist up here?
Or do have you an opinion of using found objects
to?
>> That artist is Junior in France.
He's a member of LECRIM, and he lives in Paris.
And I personally met with him and saw his
paper rolls and tried it myself as well, I
must confess.
>> We have somebody, who's name is Linda Miyahara,
and she delights in having contests at conventions,
and she will give us things like a tortilla,
a piece of plastic wrap, a toilet seat cover,
a towel, a paper pack, anything that she can
come up with to fold.
And you'd have to sit there in front of judges;
you have one minute to make a creation.
It's rather exciting.
So, yes, anything can be folded.
>> Sounds like an Iron Chef of paper, kind
of?
>> Yeah, in fact, you know, the origami community
worldwide is very well-connected.
It's a small group, but it's a huge group.
And we all know each other, and many of us
here for years, Vanessa was able to learn
about each of us by the recommendation from
one of us to another.
So, it just went around the world.
That also happens when it comes to commercial
jobs.
Maybe somebody contacts somebody and says,
"Oh, you know who you have to contact to get
this done?"
And if that person is too busy or contractually-obligated
to something else, you say, "Oh, I know just
who you should go see."
That kind of thing is actually very common.
And speaking of the toilet paper tube thing,
Richard and I have had to engineer parts folded
from crafton plastic, that are collapsible,
and ended up in satellites in orbit now right
now.
So our fingerprints, if they didn't clean
them up very well, they're in orbit right
now -- similar kind of shape, about the size
of toilet paper tube, and geometrically-designed
to collapse a certain way.
Hand-folded, sent off for gold coating.
And, there you go.
So from toilet paper tubes to orbit.
>> Hi.
This is Sally Rosenthal.
I have a question and a comment.
Vanessa, I don't think people saw you when
you first went up there.
And since you're the director.
Would you get in the camera frame please so
people know what you look like who are on
the other side of the world.
Just be in the frame so they can see you.
And then, the other thing I have an unfair
advantage because I know what's going on,
but Chris has some hats that I know people
want to see.
And I have one on.
Would you show that?
>> Yeah.
I do have a collection of silly hats.
>> Thank you.
>> I'll get that.
>> Yeah.
>> And can you repeat the question please?
>> So, yeah.
There are other things that get folded besides
paper.
Jeff was indicating that I could talk a little
bit about folding in other mediums, specifically
textile, and a little bit of the history and
relationship of how paper folding and textile
folding have crossed in my work.
So, well, here's okay. Small side thing on
silly hats just for a moment here.
They make people look silly, but they do have
some fun math behind them.
And they also have a technique for expressing
-- now, this is called "paper engineering."
This is cutting and folding.
Cutting and folding.
Paper engineering.
And this is a way that meshes and computer
3D models can get out of the computer in a
way that wouldn't happen if it was happening
with glue, which is a way that people do paper
engineering and cutting and putting things
together.
These are, instead of accumulated air that
happens when you glue tabs together to make
3D models.
Like, we're wearing these 3D models on our
head.
This is self-correcting.
So, it's accumulated perfection.
Just kind of a nice thing.
People aren't used to that.
They're used to little errors getting worse,
most of the time.
So, these adjust, because they move a little
bit, because there's no glue on them.
It's a little far away, but you can see the
connection in here.
It's a little bit like a zipper, and it allows
for, as you put each little piece together,
they can still move a little bit.
And they want to move towards the perfect
place of the two edges of the face of the
mesh.
So, I'd encourage that, when we do a little
mingling here, that everyone come and try
to put these hats on, please.
I like to collect silly portraits with the
hats on, so I'd encourage a bit of that later.
>> Yes.
So, here's a little bit of -- kind of, how
do things get folded in other mediums, textiles,
and some cross-relationship?
And also, a little bit of backwards process,
because this is a special demonstration piece
that we can see.
It looks -- I could have pasted these things
on here.
After watching this movie, you're probably
guessing that it's one piece of cloth, but
I could have pasted them on.
If you'd never seen the movie, you might have
thought I pieced them on, lots of little pieces
to get this pattern on, but we get to see
the reverse process of this ordered thing
go to chaos and flat.
>> And here's the -- we can see in low relief
the crease pattern.
Yes?
And then it goes back, and this going back
part is not exactly like what I see when I'm
doing this cross, when I'm folding this.
And this is a, kind of, classic folding of
where the lines of a tiling are expressed
as pleats.
And this style of folding is from a Japanese
teacher, [indistinct]__ Fujimoto, and I figured
out after sometime of doing the paper folding
style of these kinds of patterns where every
line becomes a pleat, there's some interesting
things about pleats expressing tilings and
lines because funny things happen at the vertices
that are unique to this expression of a folded
plane whenever the plane is paper or silk.
One of the most remarkable and interesting
things about folding a piece of paper to do
this, and folding this silk is that, a piece
of paper is highly technical to do this because
we saw, as it came apart, there was all this
distortion.
And if you try to fold this in paper and you
make all the creases and then push it together
there's a lot of distortion and the paper
needs to go through a very complex kind of
state before it gets to this final state.
And paper doesn't really want to do that and
so only 30, 40 people in the world are really
good at doing that in paper.
It's a highly technical, special niche in
origami.
This is another, kind of, pleasant contradiction
or -- in that, this technique in cloth, if
you do it a different way and take advantage
of the fact that cloth can be distorted, it
becomes a counter-example to, when we see
something complex, we always think it needed
something complex to do it.
And this is the counterexample.
This is not a complex method.
It doesn't take skill.
I can take a roomful of eleven-year-olds,
and they could walk away with a piece of folded
silk in a very complex thing.
You won't exactly believe me, because a lot
of crafts people will say, "Oh, my thing is
easy" and 30, 40 steps later it's not exactly
easy.
I could very well be one of those.
But, this is a beautiful counterexample that's
a kind of an amazing thing that pulls down
a highly technical thing so that many, many
people can do it.
It's a little bit like the right technique
like -- many people can do knitting.
It's a simple little thing.
It produces complex things, and it has levels
of complexity within the activity, but the
right medium in the right kinds of expression
for that medium are coming together in a way
where, in cloth, that is true.
And part of the interesting -- to tie back
to the origami story -- is that in order to
get to this cloth and this work and have it
be able to have its technique to be shared,
it needed to come first from paper.
And that's an interesting story that's a little
more detailed.
But I'm glad to let you know a little bit
about that and share more than what's in the
movie and what's in the wider world out there.
>> How did you plan to make this movie?
>> Well, perhaps this would be relevant to
some people out there, who have a fascination
about something.
I first learned about mathematicians doing
origami about five years ago, and I was in
no shape, way, or form a filmmaker at that
time.
But I'd always had a kind of amateur interest
in math, and generally more of a mathematical
person, but was looking for a way to explore
the connections between math and art, and
how general creativity could be applied in
both ways, you know -- together or separately.
And so, when I heard about the mathematician
in the film, Tom Hall, who was making, as
you saw, some modular pieces that were so
mathematically-based, but also so beautiful
to look at, I thought that that would be a
nice, short film.
So, I decided to visit him, and I had hoped
to make a 7- or 8-minute movie about the mathematics
of origami.
At that time, not knowing anything about what
I was about to get into.
But as time went by, Tom Hall introduced me
to Michael LeFosse.
And I slowly began to understand that what
fascinated me most about the art form was
not that, in fact, either mathematicians were
doing it, or heavy scientists or sculptors
or artists, but the fact that it was a medium
that drew all those people together or, at
least, attracted them because of its qualities.
And therein, I decided to explore the kind
of creativity that the scientists and the
mathematicians and the artists applied to
the medium itself.
And I felt that the metaphors about a square
of paper and the idea of this uniform accessibility
and democracy of the medium itself had a lot
to explore.
So that's how it happened, and then, five
years later, here we are.
>> [clapping]
>> Thank you.
Richard Alexander here.
We just -- as artists and people involved
with origami -- we just want to thank Vanessa
for the wonderful story that she's told about
this group of people.
Going back several years, a lot of these people
were folding in relative isolation.
There were small conventions and a few publications.
And when Michael and I opened the Origamido
Studio in 1996, I searched the word "origami"
on Al Gore's Internet, and I got about a million
hits.
And, when we opened our show in Waikiki last
year, I did a Google search and found 32 million
hits -- something like that -- on the word
"origami."
Congratulations.
>> Well -- not to sound too self-congratulatory
up here -- but, it's obviously an honor for
me to be able to work with the artists and
their artwork.
We did put information about all of these
artists on the film's website, which is BetweenTheFolds.com.
So if you go there, there's links to pretty
much everybody up here.
So, oh, that's right.
They're in the area -- in the Bay Area.
In fact, Robert, maybe you want to talk about
-- I don't know much about PCOC.
>> So, there are origami conventions around
the world.
And there is one called the Pacific Coast
Origami Convention.
It's in San Francisco.
It's November 5th through 8th.
About two hundred people, origami classes
at all levels, from beginner to extremely
advanced.
And, if you want to learn more about it, go
to the Origami USA website, origami-USA.org
or Google for "PCOC," "peacock," and you'll
find out what it's about and how.
Oh, yes.
There is an exhibition, and that is open to
the public.
So, you can just come to the exhibition if
you want.
>> We get asked a lot if the DVD is available.
And, as of about four days ago, we are thrilled
to say, "Yes, at our website, BetweenTheFolds.com."
>> The very first question -- I think it was
Jessie -- asked about papermaking, and the
DVD has a lot of extra footage that you didn't
see here.
So if you are interested in the details, Vanessa
has provided information such as drill down
into the DVD.
Thank you.